Du är ju lite den improved version av Joel.
Det är ett större bolag, bättre brandrecognition, du är längre än mig och du bor i Stockholm istället för utanför Göteborg.
Du har slagit mig på alla punkter här.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 minuter.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, kan det inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkommen till podden Make Sweden Stronger och idag har vi Johan Görgård från enklast kanske att säga gymgrossisten även om han är vd för hela den...
Vad säger man hela den gruppen?
Johan vad kallar man?
Health and Sports Nutrition Group.
Sen heter jag Görgård, inte Görgård.
Det brukar kallas för Göran också.
Men Health and Sports Nutrition Group är en grupp av flera e-handlare inom för hälsofräning.
Det här gymgrossisterna är den kändaste i Sverige.
Jag tror att jag har varit med i, jag vet inte, säger ett tiotal poddar, och jag tror att i över hälften av dem så har folk presenterat mig som Joel från Gymgrossisten.
Ni har ju ett otroligt etablerat namn när, dels vet man ju om vilka ni är men när man till och med tänker, det är det man tänker när man hör andra namn med gym i sig.
Hur känns det liksom att vara ledstjärnan för gymnamnet i Sverige?
Nej, det är så här shoulder of giants.
Nej men det är ju så här, vi var ju tidigt ute och det var långt före min tid.
Där var vi i mitten på 90-talet.
Och det har ju byggts liksom ett starkt varumärke tack vare en e-alldelstrend och en helståttrend under väldigt lång tid.
Och hade också stora mediasatsningar under väldigt många år där man verkligen etablerade liksom ett top of mind i kategorin.
Så det känns ju, det är ju liksom en innest att ha en sån position.
Och sen säger väl en del om dig också att du...
Att jag inte har lyckats berätta för mamma vad jag jobbar på för bolagen.
Hon tror ju fortfarande att det är gymgrossisten.
Det är så, ja.
Nej men jag tror att många spelare i vår kategori har ju ganska generiska namn också.
Så det blir den som kanske då är mest känd.
Det blir det så att man nästan refererar sig.
Sen är väl du ett mer känt ansikte än den jag är.
Jag är den mest okända e-handelspersonen i Sverige.
Tror du att det är så?
Jag har hört in någon podd innan i alla fall.
Men nej du, du kan inte få ut det.
Jag vet att när du har ställt upp i en podd, jag lyssnade sen på Sweaty Business för typ fyra år sedan.
Så lite allt med dig, Malte.
Det var ett tema på sommarfestet jag sa så att, för jag tycker att vi är en fantastisk organisation, vi är så sjukt många duktiga människor, men det är för få som inser hur duktiga vi är.
Så jag bad nästan av ursäkt att jag inte är ute och proklamerar hur bra vi är till folk.
Men det har att göra med vem, det sa jag till dem också då.
Jag är uppvuxen i en liten stad i Norrland, eller södra Norrland, där jantelagen är ganska stor, man skryter inte, man skrävlar inte.
Det är lite som ett ok säkert att jag inte vill...
Och när jag gör det, du är ut och swingar mycket, men du gör det på ett naturligt och bra sätt.
Så fort jag ska skryta eller framhäva oss, får jag bara käta shit, det här kommer fram fel.
Så att jag har såhär...
Däremot så försöker jag bygga relationer och bygga sammanhang på andra sätt, med personliga relationer.
Så, och det känner jag att det är...
Men det finns ju verkligen en poäng också, det märker man ju såhär att det är många som framförallt bygger sitt eget varumärke genom att synas och höras.
Och där är inte min egen.
Men är det inte för att ni är just toppdogger?
Jag kan ju svinga lite eftersom vi är så pass små.
Om du går ut och säger, ja fan, MM Sports det är ett skitbolag, det hade ju inte varit så populärt.
Men om jag säger det så är det inte så känsligt.
Nu behöver vi inte...
Nu menar vi inte att de är skitsatte.
Men de är ju ett skitbolag eller vad vi är duktiga.
Det blir ju olika uppfattningar.
Det finns någonting med det här entreprenörsämnet också.
Du svarar bara för dig själv sen.
Jag svarar för någonting annat och då...
Och sen när man störer om man har viss governance.
Så det påverkar lite grann säkert också hur man agerar i vissa sammanhang.
Du kan liksom ta ut svängarna med det.
Känner du dig låst av det?
Nej.
För det första så trivs jag ju med det.
Jag behöver ju inte, så att det passar mig ganska väl såhär.
Men jag tror att, eller vad menar du, att vara ett stort bolag eller relativt stort bolag och sådant?
Ja exakt.
När du har ett så pass stort bolag som har funnits så pass länge, så att ni på något sätt lite inkör dig kanske över tid, men kanske framförallt liksom värderingsmässigt vart, det här är våran arena, här ska vi synas, här ska vi inte synas, det här är vårt formspråk, det här är våran.
Blir det att du måste spela med i det, eller får du göra din, kan du leva ut dina fantasier?
Det är en jätteintressant frågeställning, för jag tror det som gör många nya aktörer är att stora bolag är långsamma.
Och det tror jag till dels är sant, för att du blir som du beskriver, vinkör dina ljusspår.
Men sen är man också, vi är mycket mer av marknaden än vad till exempel, ja men du är ju så på stor nu, men många andra aktörer är så här, vi måste först sälja för 1,2 miljarder och sedan växa.
Så det blir som, då kan man inte heller bara göra vad som helst.
Och det är inte respektfullt för mina medarbetare, våra kunder och våra ägare.
Först måste vi hantera det som basen och sedan kan vi ta ut svängarna.
Jag tänkte faktiskt på det när du, du var med i någon artikel här på ehandel.se, då hade ni sålt för, ni hade vuxit från 1,19 miljarder till 1,23 miljarder eller sånt där.
Då tänkte jag på det att det var en bra artikel för att ni hade gått med vinst istället, eller ni hade ökat vinsten rätt mycket.
Men hade ni till exempel tappat omsättning till 1,1 miljarder, då hade folk varit besvikna, men 1,1 miljarder är rätt många kilo proteinpulver.
Det är lite sjukt att fastna i det här, som du säger, ni måste först sälja för det och sen måste ni växa.
Ja men exakt, och då blir det, och det påverkar än tror jag, och jag tror ändå på någonting, man kan bli defensivt, man kan bli rädd för att göra fel och så där.
Det tror jag liksom, du måste hitta en balans i det där.
Du kan inte rycka upp allt, för då riskerar du också allt.
Vi skulle inte kunna rebranda gymgrusisten och heta någonting annat och göra det rosa eller i blått, utan vi måste vara svartgula och heta gymgrusisten.
Det är rimligt.
Ståndetrippsen är liksom ett viktigt varumärke för oss, vi kan inte bara kasta det över bord.
Samtidigt tror jag att hur vi tar ut kommunikation och hur vi har förmåga att ta oss an nya kategorier, där tror jag att det hela gäller att skapa en kultur i organisationen som också gör att man vågar göra grejer.
Det är mitt ansvar och det är ledningens ansvar.
Hur gör man det då?
Man skapar trygghet och man låter människor vara de de är.
Jag tror det finns en otrolig kraft i att låta människor få vara sig själva men också mäta det man gör.
Vara fact based men vara tolerant för individen och också tolerant för misstag och någonstans också mäta insats.
Inte alltid bara mäta resultat.
Resultat kommer ibland, ibland kommer de inte.
Om man bara får resultaten tenderar folk att också bli bara göra safe bets.
Hur många anställda är ni?
Det är det som ser roligt så här.
För nu framstår det oss som stora, vi är ju inte stora.
Det beror ju på vad du jämför med.
Vi är 130 totalt, 140 totalt men cirka 65 tjänstemän och resten i lagret ungefär.
Hur många känner du till namnet?
Vi flyttar i lagret precis då.
Så jag känner alla tjänstemän och kvinnor vid namn.
Vi har flyttat kunds, tjänst precis, kundservice.
Där är det några blanksposs.
Men överens känner jag alla tjänstemän vid namn.
Jag vet hur gamla deras barn är, ish.
Jag vet vad de är intresserade av.
Så det är väl också så här, mitt ledarskap bygger ju också på att jag vill, att jag behandlar alla lika, lite för någon som sagt.
Men jag tror ju genuint på det som jag sa tidigare, att få människor att känna sig trygga och sedda.
Så tror jag att man presterar.
Du kan ju få backning på det faktiskt för att vi har ju en kille på vårt lag som har jobbat och ser.
Och jag skulle träffa dig någon gång i Stockholm, detta är väl ett halvår sedan eller någonting, jag kommer inte ihåg riktigt.
Men då sa han, ja fan Johan, det är en bra chef, han är jävligt bra på karaoke, han sjöng ju den här låten en gång på en julfest.
Så då har du ändå gjort dig populär bland lagerfolket.
Jag vill säga, one trick pony, jag kan en låt.
Du kan en låt.
Nu visste jag inte var vi var någonstans.
Hör det här, till samma blyghet att, eller blyghet med Jantelag, du har ju jobbat inom Orkla-koncernen som äger HSNG-gruppen.
Du har väl varit på det här bolaget i extremt många år.
Ja, länge har det varit.
Är det också en sån här lojalitetsgrej som finns i Norrland?
Nej, absolut inte.
Jag har faktiskt säkert upp mig tre gånger från Orkla, men de har liksom pulled me right back in.
Anledningen till att jag har varit kvar i den kontexten är ju för att jag har fått göra massa roliga grejer och nya grejer, och lärt mig sjukt mycket och varit runt människor som jag trivs.
Så att de gånger jag sa upp mig idag, det var för att då kände jag att jag hade stagnerat, och då kom det en ny möjlighet.
Och det jobb jag har nu tycker jag är fantastiskt roligt.
Jag tycker kombinationen mellan teknik och retail, den här extremt avancerade som det ändå kan vara med det banala är jäkligt kul.
Det handlar bara om att sälja en produkt, men samtidigt så är det så sjukt komplex.
Det gör att man, och i en kategori som hälsa, som också är så sjukt förnylig om den ändras hela tiden.
Jag tänker att förutom morde och liknande så är ju kanske hälsa eller träning eller kostig skott för den delen, det är en sådan där bransch som extremt många vill starta bolag inom.
Det känns ju som att är man, är man influencer och man når över en viss gräns, då ska man starta kostig skottsbolag eller någon sorts.
Hur har ni haft?
Tänker ni på de människorna?
Har ni någon strategi mot dem eller tar ni in de här svarmärken eller bara försöker ni köra över dem?
Vad är er på riktigt?
Det är ju inte grunden, nej exakt.
Det är i grunden det politiska svaret, det är väldigt positivt att folk är så här intresserade att vi nog vill agera på dem.
Ja herregud, ajamen.
Såklart att om vi säger att marknaden växer någonstans 7% per år, och så kommer det hundra nya aktörer eller 50 som tar de där 7%, så är det en utmaning för våra etablerade aktörer att växa på sådant marknad.
Samtidigt så tror jag att det de gör är också att de bibehåller ett intresse för kategorin.
De tenderar ju ofta att inte vara lite, vad säger man, dagslända.
Ja.
Så.
Och det finns också lite andra aspekter.
Vi sätter ju stolthet i att ta fram bra produkter på marknaden och säkerställer det i alla former vi kan, livsmedelssäkerhetsmässigt och så vidare.
Och då blir ju, vad heter det, menar jag så att en aktör som, en en mann-show där kanske inte har samma möjligheter till det.
Jag ska inte säga att alla är så, men jag tror att det bidrar positivt på ett sätt, sen är det lite stök för hur de kanske marknadsför vissa grejer i vissa fall.
Att de lovar saker som inte håller emellan.
Men i grunden så är vi så pass stora, vi har så pass etablerade positioner och klara av att växa på det.
Det ska vi klara av ändå liksom.
Vi har givetvis kollat på kosttillskott genom åren, och jag tror att jag har kikat på det seriöst tre gånger, men jag tror att alla tänker att det är större marginaler inom kosttillskotten än vad det är.
Det finns säkert lite vitaminer och sånt där, men rent protein och de stora mängder produkterna, det är fan inte mycket pengar.
Det flutterer ganska brutalt.
Det kan man säga till alla som lyssnar.
Håller bort dem kan man säga.
Om du tittar på när jag började mitt jobb, det var typ sex år sedan nu, då tittar man på vad är samlad ebit-nivå för aktörerna i Norden?
Då tror jag att det var ytterligare 0 kronor.
Vi tjänade lite pengar och det var någon annan som tjänade, men väldigt många förlorade pengar, så total lönsamheten var cirka 0 kronor.
Nu har det blivit lite bättre för många i branschen, men det är fortfarande på tok för låga nivåer för att det ska, tycker jag, det är mitt största uppdrag att vi ska lyckas tjäna mer pengar.
För jämför du kostnadskapsprisnivån i Sverige med övriga i Europa, var det mycket billigare i Sverige och i Norden än det var där i södra Europa.
Det brukar ju vara omvända.
Så det är en väldigt konkurrensutsatt marknad.
Men inte det lite erat fel?
Jo.
Nej men det är en bra spaning.
Det har varit en extremt konkurrensutsatt, mycket såhär, det tror jag till och med personligt, det här var innan min tid också såhär, och det var så extremt fokuserat på växt för många.
Växt var det enda man fokuserade på.
Och det har alltid kommit en ny aktör som har hela tiden velat växa.
Och så har vi etablerade aktörer då inte haft kyla när det är att kanske lita på vår position och våra varumärken så att vi också har följt med i den spiralen.
Men jag tror att ni upplever att det är en hälsosammare marknad nu.
Om det kanske har varit under vissa perioder.
Men det är absolut bra för konsumenten då någonstans.
För en hälsomedveten.
Men inte så bra för lönsamheten ibland.
Det är lite sjukt om den samlade kosttillskottssumman har noll i vinst.
Det är bara ett utbyte av pengar mot produkter.
Lite halvvisare.
Det är religiöst.
Varför håller man på med det här?
Exakt.
Det var väl mer.
Vi tittade på mer traditionella kosttillskottssumman.
Vitaminer, mineral.
Om vi tittar på de aktörerna så har de haft en mer lönsamhet.
Men sportnutriktionsaktörer var det jag tittade mest på.
Men är du en träningsnerd och sånt där?
Jag har aldrig, men jag har inte sett sådär jättemånga gånger, men jag har aldrig liksom hört dig säga fan jag drog ett nytt marklyftsrekord igår eller har du smakat den här smaken på kosttillskotts, Joel?
Nej, jag kommer inte att prova det såhär.
Två meter långa, tunn små stickor.
Jag känner ju att, nej men du är ju ganska lång.
Och ni är ju, eller du, nu ska jag se hur detta ska låta inte som en fanboy-grej här, men du är ju lite den improved version av Joel.
Det är ett större bolag, bättre brandrecognition, du är längre än mig och du bor i Stockholm istället för utanför Göteborg, så jag tror att du har slagit mig på alla punkter här.
Jag är ju två ungar, har du tre eller?
Nej jag har två, två grabbar.
Jag har också två pojkar.
Hade du haft en till så hade det varit som att du slog mig på det också.
Är du en träningsnöd eller är du inte?
Jag tränar, jag gillar idrotter, jag tränar en hel del, men jag är ju inte den här byggartypen, historiskt så.
Jag har ju jobbat med hälsoprodukter ganska länge, så den är egentligen sen 2010 kanske.
Så jag kan ju kategorin, och jag är intresserad av kategorin, men framförallt de som jag har inledde och det som är, jag är intresserad av människor.
Jag tycker det är kul att förstå den här kategorin och förstå de som märker i den och de som använder produkterna.
Men det finns ju väldigt många fler på kontoret som är starkare än mig och som äter mer kostskott än jag gör.
Fast jag gör det alltså, jag har käkat kreativt varje dag, jag har käkat Nantlus, jag har käkat Omega 3, jag tar B-vitamin, jag har elektrolyter varje morgon.
Så jag kör protein givetvis flera gånger om dagen.
Så jag är verkligen inte såhär, jag är där, men jag ser nog inte ut som ett sån och kanske inte det har.
Jag fattar.
I gymgrossistens ögon så är du inte den perfekta människan än, utan du har några steg kvar.
På väg, på väg dit.
På väg om några år, yes.
När man pratar, vad ska man säga då?
Vi säger protein för det är nästan lättast att köra om den marknaden.
Är det den största produkten?
Ja, kategorin är den största.
För det har ju gått lite, när jag var liten, eller vad man ska säga, när jag var ung och började träna, då drack man ju yoghurt eller typ choklad.
Sedan kom det ju en period när allting smakade godis.
Det var liksom olika godiska och sånt där.
När man pratar trender i detta går det liksom trender inom smaker eller är det bara att det blir mer och mer spejsade smaker?
Det tenderar ju, det är som i alla kategorier, eller i alla fall ett sånt du äter.
Det finns storkälla, de tenderar att vara där hela tiden.
Sedan så kommer det in lite i svansen som blir såhär som blir såhär uttrappande.
Och det är ju, det är ju poplar vanilj, jordgubb som är de stora.
Sedan kan du kalla dem lite annorlunda.
Men smakmässigt så är det det som är mest populärt.
Sedan är det väl så att de som är hardcore consumers äter ju mycket av det här.
Så de vill ju också ha variation för det blir ganska tröttsamt över tid.
Så det finns ju definitivt ett behov.
I och med i 80 tror jag att vi har närmare 30 smaker.
Så det finns ju verkligen ett behov att kunna variera.
Men det är fortfarande de stora källorna som är det som går.
Sedan så finns det innovation i kateberin.
Det kommer ju många nya veganska proteinkällor fortfarande litet.
Men vi tror väl att det också kommer att växa.
Men också för att vasle protein som kommer från mjölk och hos produktion.
Den produktionen ökar inte så mycket när sportinton ökar, så vi måste hitta nya källor för tiden.
Det finns clearway-varianter som är genomskinliga, mer som lemonader.
Det finns innovation och det finns smart-variationer.
Det är just det som jag beskrev tidigare som också gör det intressant.
Sedan har du tillväxten i målgrupper som också är väldigt intressant.
Du har ju gått ifrån att det var sådana som du gjorde, att få utvalda på 90-talet.
Sedan växte det markant under 2010-talet.
Men mest hos killar, men nu har kvinnor, det är ju en stor målgrupp nu, men också äldre, alltså pensionärer.
Det är ju en viktig mål för att muskelmassa är det viktigaste aspekten.
Ja, jag har faktiskt fått det de senaste veckorna.
Folk har sett min tröja, jag har ju alltid en tröja som det står gymkompaniiet på.
Då har jag fått ett par damer som har kommit fram och börjat prata med mig om kreatin och frågat, ska man ta det?
Det verkar vara en jättestark träff att man ska ta det bland äldre.
Ja, kvinnor kring klimaterier, kring klimateriet.
Märker ni det i försäljningen?
Ja, kreatin går extremt starkt.
Det växer som tusan.
Är det samma dåliga marginal där eller är det en produkt jag ska ta in?
Nej men det är väl det.
Kommer inte jag att rita.
Nej men det är kanske lite bättre, men inte...
Kreatin är ju å andra sidan snor billigt.
Jag har för mig att man får typ 100 portioner för 150 spänn eller något sånt där.
Jag har för mig att det är längre billigt.
Det var också i samband med covid och i samband med OS i...
Vad är OS i pek?
Det var någon aktivitet i alla fall i Kina som gjorde att man ville få bort det som utsläpp.
Så man stängde ner mycket av produktionen och så var det svårt att få ut varor.
Det var en sån perfekt cocktail av problem som gjorde att det gick inte att få tag på kreatin under de här perioderna och då stack ut priserna i taket.
Den har väl normaliserats lite grann nu.
Hur funkar det att jobba med...
Ni säljer ju färskvaror men det är liksom inte en daglig...
Eller färskvaror, men ni säljer produkter med bäst före datum.
Men ni är ingen daglig varuhandel där man går in och handlar på ett ICA så ni kan ju liksom inte bara...
Det rullar ju inte en gång om dagen hela assortimentet, gissar jag, utan ni måste köpa en ganska stora volymer.
Hur jävla mäckig är den logistiken?
Nej men det är väl det som också skiljer en aktör som som tjänar pengar och inte tror jag.
Det är ju liksom, alla fall över tid.
Inte nödvändigtvis.
Alltså hur du hanterar ditt lager och hur du särskilt att du inte förköper dig på grejer och att du snurrar det snabbt och får en avkastning på kapitalet snabbt.
Så jag tror det är sjukt, där kan man ju gå bort sig liksom, rejält.
Och det handlar om att inte göra så, att optimera det på ett bra sätt.
Just också som du beskrev, det är ju ganska mycket kampanjer så att säkerställa också att du har produkter när du väl vill sälja dem.
Så att du kan inte heller gå för att hela den snurran, det vi kallar för S&OP och Sales and Operation Planning, det är viktigt.
Och att du sitter med tillgång på produkter som matchar efterfrågan.
Hur ser du ett sånt team?
Jag är lite fascinerad av verksamheter som jag upplever som komplexa, och jag upplever er som komplexa.
Du får jämföra min kompagniet i alla fall.
Det är väl också det vi jobbar med, för jag tror också att även för vår storlek så är vi komplexa.
Så hur kan vi göra oss enklare?
Men just kopplat till den delen, det finns de som är mycket mer raffinerade än oss där.
Men vi har ju mjukvara som gör prognoser över hur mycket som förväntas sälja av en viss produkt på skruvnivå.
Och sen bygger den upp produktiv, vad som förväntas och hur den ska förväntas öka.
Men följs det upp hela tiden och så sitter det ett marknadsföringsteam som säljer av det?
För ni måste väl ändå planera?
Nej, det är en operativt inköp som följer upp det och sen så lägger vi in kampanjprognoser när vi vet att vi ska göra något extra.
Och sen avropar folk på det liksom.
Så det är en process, det är väl lite så här processstyrt.
Och styr man det mot konkurrensen?
För ni har ju, vad ska man säga, ni har ju några etablerade konkurrenter som också har funnit, några nya liksom, men några som också har funnits över lång tid.
Har ni typ samma säljcykler, eller går ni och bemöter varandra?
Är det så här, okej vi backar undan i februari, så tar ni i mars, eller är det snarare så här, att fan vi vet att de kommer i januari, så jävlar ska vi också ta dem.
Hur funkar det?
Vi vill ju slå dem hela tiden liksom.
Så det är liksom en grund, vi ska alltid vinna.
Och sen tänker man ju inte alltid, såklart, inte alltid vinna på pris, till exempel.
Så att, men vi vill ju alltid vinna kunden så.
Kan man inte det om man är störst?
För ni är väl störst, är ni inte det?
Ja det är väl återigen det väl som du...
Är det inte inköpsvolymer som det handlar om?
Jo men, men det är väl, det är väl lite det som du, så här, om man är stor eller störst, så är man också marknaden, så lite mer så här, så att om, om vi någonstans, det är det som också gör att det är lättare att vara en liten aktör för då kan du, hur kan du prisa in dig för du behöver inte, om jag skulle sänka priset på, till exempel kreativt, hur kommer det drabba hela min volym, som är väldigt stor då där.
Så, medans en aktör som, som har lite volym att försvara, som all ny volym blir en ny kund, då är det lättare att prisa in dig så här.
Så det är inte alls lätt att, så är det klart att vi borde ha en skalfördel i inköpsvolym så, men då får man också komma ihåg att mycket av det här är kommodde till produkter.
Så att det liksom, går runt och tror att en stor aktör hela tiden kan vinna på pris.
Ja, i teorin kan ni göra det men det, och det går ju såklart att göra det men, kommer det resultera att du tjänar mer pengar eller att du får...
Det behöver inte vara en sund affär i slutändan.
Nej, precis.
Det handlar om att hitta en sund balans i det där.
Är det det du sitter med?
Vad gör man liksom som...
Visst är ni fyra bolag i grunden?
Är det så?
Alltså vi är, man kan säga så här, vi har en, om man ska förenkla det så, vi har en egen own brands affär som handlar om produktutveckla och ta fram.
Vi säljer det både externt.
Vi har en DBH affär som är ganska stor.
Vi har en B2B affär som går till gym, till posterskapsbutiker och sports retail.
Och sen har vi en online affär.
Så.
Och den online affären är uppdelad på ett antal retail brands då.
Okej, det är samma back-end men det är ett front-end.
Ja, det är samma.
Eller olika front-end, förlåt.
Ja, men exakt.
Olika front-end, samma organisation, samma teknik, samma lager.
Är det inte skitsvårt att jobba med att vara grossist till butiker och andra leverantörer när man är i en sån marknad som redan är så prispressad?
Det måste vara jättesvårt att hitta balans där.
Ja, det är en bra spaning, det är det ju också.
Sen får man hitta var finns det marginal i värdekedjan för att ha en sund affär för oss och för våra kunder, våra bit-vi kunder så att alla kan vinna på det.
Det är ju mycket i våra egna varumärken så ser vi en jättepotential i.
Det är starka i rätt för tidigt segment.
Så där tror vi också.
Det är en spaning framåt också.
Vi tror ju mycket mer på, vi tror på produktvarumärken.
Och vi tror att hela retailaffären också är kraft av AI commerce och allt vad det heter.
Då tror vi att det blir ännu mer viktigt att vara en bra, att ha starka produktvarumärken som konsumenten faktiskt konsumerar snarare än att ha ett fräscht och härligt retail brand.
Jag fattar, men det jag ska komma till var lite, vad gör du på dagarna egentligen förutom att snacka med kollegor?
Jag försöker undrika.
Vad gör jag på dagen?
Vad har man som huvudroll när det är ens, jag vet ju vad jag gör men vi gör en väldigt enkel verksamhet.
Jag ska syssa med inköp och ekonomi och så ska jag snacka med kollegor och se till att saker rullar.
Det är väldigt enkelt.
Vad gör man när det är en massa olika säljvägar, en massa olika grejer och vad lägger du din tid på?
Över några såhär, var ska vi?
Det gör man inte hela tiden.
Men sätta en tydlig strategi, en tydlig prioritering.
Det är dag ett av året så vi ska bli lite större.
Varje dag två liksom.
Sen handlar det någonstans av, tack för att jag har ett bra team.
Nu gjorde du full lugnare.
Jag tänker samtidigt att jag ska svara.
Jag måste säga det uppenbara snabbt.
Men bra team och sen handlar det om att följa upp det på olika sätt.
Och sen handlar det om att, och sen är jag mycket mer av en cowboy än vad du tror då.
Så jag är också inne och petar grejer.
Det handlar ju någonstans om att, där allting rullar på, det låter jag ju någonstans vara.
Och sen där jag ser avvike eller där jag upplever att här måste vi göra förändringar, då är jag också mycket tätare på, ställer mer frågor, följer upp och är jobbigare.
Men någonstans också, det som är kanske, också skillnaden när man blir lite större, återigen vi är inte så stora, men lite större än er, det blir att jag anställer ju folk som jag tror på och som jag vet är duktiga, och då måste jag också låta att de får göra jobbet.
Så att om det går hyfsat bra, då är ju mitt jobb också lättare än när det går sämre.
Jag får ju också mindre frågor från min styrelseutförande när det går bättre.
Jag fattar.
Jag vet inte om du har ett svaret.
Nej, jag fattar.
Du visar vart uppmärksamheten i organisationen ska ligga.
Ja, det är väl en...
Ja, jag använder det.
Så är det nog.
Jag måste ju också ta in att ni jobbar ju faktiskt lite med gymutrustning också, även om det inte är er primära affär på något sätt.
Och du behöver ju inte nämna siffror och sånt där.
Är det en bra combo att sälja skivstänger ihop med en proteinbar?
Ja, ett slag tänker jag det.
När jag var nervös under covid så tänkte jag att här finns en untapp market, vi kan få hela kundens gymupplevelser.
Och sen det som du någonstans hintar i, det är ju en helt annan apparat, framförallt logistikmässigt, och sjukt komplext.
Jag är ju imponerad över du och de andra som verkar det här.
För det är ju svårt att få ihop kalkylen hela vägen, när man jobbar med så tunga och bökiga grejer.
Så att det vi gör, eller den strategi vi har, vi jobbar med dropship på det som konkurrerar med er mycket.
Sen har vi lättare redskap och verktyg, redskap som vi kan hantera internt förslag, som också kan gå i samma flöde som övriga i vår automation.
Där ser vi att vi kan få någon typ av lönsamhet i det.
Men det är, och i likhet så tror jag det som du också är inne på, att jobba med stora, bulkiga saker, och helt plötsligt bara jobba med produkter med hållbarhetstider.
Det är också en komplex kombination.
Men vi har valt, vi tror i och med att vi har ett etablerat varumärke, vi känner också att vi har kunder redan, så tror jag också att det finns en sån här, när folk går in på Google shopping och söker på viktskiva eller träningsykkel, så tror vi att vi kan fånga en del kunder på vårt varumärke, kommentera dem och sagt att de kan vara på det.
Men har ni aldrig tänkt, förutom under covid då, men i efterhand, har ni aldrig tänkt att, och på inget sätt vill jag övertyga dig, men har ni aldrig tänkt att vi ska in i denna marknaden och göra det på riktigt, det här kan vi ta över.
Men det är väl samma spaning där då, ni tjänar ju heller inte med pengar, det finns ju inget som tjänar pengar.
Det är ännu värre, det är Leiko som tjänar pengar.
Men sen är det liksom 1-2 procent, då känner jag såhär, då går jag heller nån annanstans.
Faktiskt, om jag ska aldrig göra det så.
Jag tror att det är sunt, men okej, fair enough.
Ni har ju också, ni säljer också träningskläder, är det samma sak där?
Är det också en dropshippingaffär som hanteras så?
Ja, den har vi själv.
Men hur är det att hantera?
Är du inte trött på den returproblematiken?
Nej, faktiskt inte.
Jag tycker att den är, och det är ju så här, det är ju också, det är ju en enormt stor marknad liksom.
Och det är också en så här, jättekonkurrensutsatt marknad.
Och det är också, investerar sig väldigt mycket i teknik i handeln för det liksom, så det är ganska utmanande att vara relevant, där shopping, upplevelsemässigt när man är, det är nog en ganska liten affär vi har.
Men har det ju öppnat, förlåt jag bara avbryter det hela tiden, men det är för att jag tycker att det är jävligt spännande det här ju.
Det är som att jag får fråga ut, ja, ibland finns det ju poddar som jag får lyssna på, och ibland är det för mig, detta är ju i allra högsta grad för mig.
Men vi har ju haft, det går ju skitdåligt för XXL, och Decathlon stängde i Sverige till exempel här för ett tag sedan.
Är det liksom en öppning för er att gå in i vissa grejer, eller ligger de helt utanför er konkurrensbild?
Nej men det kan absolut finnas en viss potential.
Sen är XXL en viktig kund till oss också, vi säljer in en hel del konstruktioner till dem, så vi hoppas ju såklart att de ska ha en framgångskrik framtid.
En konstruktion.
Ja jag vet inte vad som händer där inne.
Men, så det är väl liksom, sen tror jag i kraft av att kategorin är så enorm stor, jag vet inte ens kategori i värdet, jag bara vet att den är tillräckligt stor, för att vi med vår kund och kopplingen till det vi håller på med, så tror jag att vi kan absolut ta en position där och tjäna bra om pengar också, för att vi har då infrastrukturen för att hantera.
Men det kommer aldrig bli vår viktigaste kategori, det tror jag inte.
Men den kan säkert bli väsentligt större än den är idag.
Och jag tycker upplever också att kulturhanteringen är hanterbar för oss i alla fall.
Jag tänkte, ni hade ju ett lager i Trollhättan förr.
Ni gjorde väl en lagerflytt för två eller tre år sedan?
Ja, drygt två år sedan.
Jag försökte för övrigt få tag på er gamla hyresvärd, för att våra data har gått utom två år, så vi försöker hitta en större lokal, och då försöker jag kolla på gamla gymgrossisten lokaler.
Så jag går i gamla hjulspår där också.
Ja, den är tydlig tror jag.
Ja, det är för jävligt.
Men hur gick den lagerflytten?
Kan du ta oss lite med på hur jag älskar logistik?
Kan du bara förklara, har ni ett sånt här superlager som snurrar runt och inga människor går runt i?
Ja, väsentligt färre människor.
Så det var mycket mer tomt fabrik i förra laget.
Det fanns en otrolig charm i det också.
En härlig kultur, folk gick runt och high-fived i korridorerna.
Men nu är det mycket mer av det som du beskrev.
Vi har mer än halverat antalet medarbetare på grund av automationen.
Var det det som var grunden till flytten?
Vi höll på att växa ut ur vårt fördåande lager.
Vi låg i trällhåll, vi såg att logistiskt, med vissa konkurrenter vi möter med deras ledtider, kände vi att vi behöver ha närmare till distriktionscentraler.
Sen såg vi att vi hade en potential att öka effektiviteten genom att automatisera.
Så det var egentligen tredjedelat.
Det var en jättemannöver, det är det största förändringsprojektet jag har gjort i min karriär, som jag i alla fall har ansvarat för.
Jag tror att vi har hållit på i tvååring till planeringen.
Det är en investering som är så stor att många ska involveras i sånt.
Så det är en granlageruppgift, mycket kopplat till människor.
Hur man säkerställer att du går från ett lag som funnits i 20 år, inte på exakt samma ställe men människor har varit väldigt länge.
Hur hanterar vi dem med respekt och säkerställer att vi kan slussa dem vidare i yrkeslivet på ett bra sätt givet.
Det har vi skrivit tidigare och hoppas att ni genomsyrar våra värderingar, men också hur vi startar upp ett helt nytt lager med människor som aldrig har jobbat med det här, vissa kanske har jobbat i lager men helt nya processer, helt ny teknik liksom och även helt nytt management.
Det tog ju ett slag innan vi var helt, nu går det jättebra men i första perioden fanns det ju utmaningar så klart.
Gör man skiftet liksom bara rakt av, nu är det klart i gamla, nu är det klart i nya och så får de nya börja helt plötsligt hantera den volymen.
Det måste vara ganska knepigt liksom.
Nej men exakt, vi hade ju inte så här gradvis övergång då.
Så vi flyttade över delar av sortimentet, steg för steg.
Men det är inte så att om du när du väl har påbörjat flytten så är det svårt att gå tillbaka.
Framförallt, du minns inte exakt hur vi gjorde det med alla detaljer.
Men det var ju point of no return.
Så du satte igång förflyttningen, då har du gjort en testning som du känner dig tvig med.
Sen så är det en gradvis förflyttning.
Du flyttade, jag tror vi började med att flytta lågrotationsprodukter som skulle in i Autostore.
Sen så flyttade vi gradvis med snabbrörliga och så flyttade vi med det här skrymm som kanske inte alls roteras ofta på slutet.
Så det var en manöver, den fungerade bra.
Det är allt sånt där som går att planera för.
Det gick ju bra men sen gick det alltid upp saker som det inte.
Vad var största krånglet på vägen?
Jag tror till exempel att vi underskattade hur vi lagrade in, de personal som lagrade in saker i Autostore som aldrig har gjort det.
Och du vet ju såhär, om du lägger in någonting i en låda som går in i en stor jättekub såhär, om det läggs fel där, vilket jag tror att det görs lite grann där inne i spelet, så blir det enormt mycket stök.
Så det hade vi vissa utmaningar med.
Vi hade också utmaningar med viss returhantering.
Jag gillar hur du håller tillbaka i den.
Fanns det någon som hette Bosse som bara lade in allt på A32?
Nej, jag tror att det fanns folk som inte fick lika mycket förutsättningar för att lyckas med grejerna.
Ja, det märks att du varit chef länge.
Fan, ni pratar så snällt till Junge och systemt.
Det är en returantering som också är en jättetutmaning i början tror jag.
Sen har effektiviteten gradvis förbättrat också.
Nu är vi på jättefina effektivitetsstal men det har också varit en resa.
Och det måste man vara inställd för också.
Man kan bli som inte går runt och tro att allt ska förrulla från start.
Det måste finnas tid att låta en ny organisation sätta sig.
Om du är alltför nervös och alltför stressad i det där, då skapar du också en nervös och stressad organisation som inte brukas.
När man har en sådan här, vad ska man säga, träningsbranschen har ju en tendens att ha människor i sig som inte är drömmare kanske, men de är ofta rätt passionerade för träning.
Det är lite så.
Jag tänker att gymgrossistern är ett sådant varumärke dit.
Kanske folk har sökt sig för att jag gillar träning, då vill jag jobba och se er.
Man tänker liksom inte att man ska jobba på lagret, utan man tänker att man ska jobba med träning.
Hur gör man för att bibehålla de människorna så att de inte börjar plugga till PT sen och försvinner iväg?
Om människor har en dröm så tror jag att man ska eftersträva den, annars ska man ångra sig, jag heller då låter dem söka den drömmen och om man ångrar sig komma tillbaka i så fall.
Jag tror inte att det hindrar folks utvecklingar, ett sätt att skapa ett vinnande lag eller vinnande organisation.
Så, du fick ju en peak till dig där indirekt.
Men jag tror så om det är svar.
Men sen tror jag att det är klart att det finns de som tror att jobba på gymresisten handlar om att jobba med träning, men jobba på gymresisten handlar om, dels om du beskriver att plocka varor på lagret, sitta och analysera Excel.
Så det är ju, och det är ju klart att det finns ett väldigt stort element av träning och koppling till träningsmågrupperna i alla dess former, men mycket handlar om samma sak som du kanske gör på vilken e-handlare som helst, eller vilken annan produktbolag som helst.
Så man måste nog vara inställd på det också, inte bara tro att det handlar om träning.
Men om man ska bygga upp den här, visst har det varit, säg man HSNG, visst har det varit där i typ åtta år eller något sånt där?
Nej, inte sex.
Jag tror sex och tvåtals kanske.
Om jag nu här de närmaste åren ska bygga upp en liten ledningsgrupp, eller jag behöver ha, just där, vad behöver man tänka på kring ett sånt gäng människor?
Att du trivs för dem.
Alltså, det är det viktigaste.
Du trivs för dem, du litar på dem, och de är inte helt strötta i samma form.
Att de kompletterar dig.
Vilken aspekt är det de behöver skilja sig?
För det tror jag är en viktig fråga.
Jag är i alla fall svår för att skapa grupper, där det blir alltför mycket konflikt för att man ska vara olika.
Det tror jag är så här, den typen av olika tror inte jag på riktigt.
Jag tror att ett sammanhang där folk trivs med varandra är bättre än de omvända.
Men däremot så tror jag, till exempel jag är ju ganska snabb till beslut, jag är ganska relativt impulsiv och numbers driven.
Men jag behöver komplettera för människor som är mycket mer strukturerade, har mycket mer koll på process till exempel.
Det är liksom någonting jag måste se till att jag kompletteras med sen.
Men jag tänker inte att de behöver, värderingsmässigt ser jag gärna att de har samma värderingar.
Medan kompetensmässigt ser jag att jag gärna har någonting som kompletterar mig.
Jag funderar lite på samma sak.
Jag är ju hetsig om det inte märks.
Nu det tror jag, det ser jag direkt.
Eller det är en grej jag verkligen tänker på.
Jag tror att 90% av mina samtal börjar med ordet sammanfatta.
Jag har lite svårt för när saker tar mer än två minuter.
Men alla de som jag jobbar med är ju extremt mycket mer noggranna.
De har ju koll på saker, jag har ju inte koll på någonting.
De rättar ju mig 90 gånger om dagen.
Ja men det är ju lite, ja och jag drar, man kan också extrapoleras av, om man sitter med någon datapunkt så tror man detta att det är så.
Så kommer folk att vara, men Johan måste se helheten.
Tänk igenom det här.
Och risken, eller det jag känner, det jag upplever att, vilket också kanske blir svagare, att ju längre du är i verkarend miljö, där du kompletteras av dina olika, du kan dra din personlighet ännu längre.
Så att det blir en utmaning.
Den dagen, du ska ju jobba med det där hela ditt liv då, så det blir väl inget för dig, men den dagen jag får sparken så här, hur kommer, när man har utvecklat en sida av sig, säkert då?
Jag var i en extremt tydlig sådan situation.
Jag skulle planera en grej här ihop med ett gäng andra människor som jag aldrig har pratat med tidigare, eller det var en svensk sexare då.
Men jag är ju så van vid att jobba med mina kolleger, och jag är så van vid att de jobbar på ett visst sätt, jag jobbar på ett visst sätt, men nu skulle jag helt plötsligt sättas in i ett sammanhang med människor som jag aldrig har snackat med.
Det var det sjukaste jag har varit med om.
Jag kan ju liksom inte fungera i en setting som inte är uppbyggd för mig och mitt sätt att vara.
Alla kunder runt.
Jag är på att bli galen och så snackar jag med min fru då, och bara, fan älskling jag vet inte vad jag ska göra.
Hon bara, men är du typ fem år, är du van vid att alla människor daltar med dig som att du är, det är bara att jag umgås ju inte med vänner eller personer som inte pratar på mitt sätt längre.
Jag bemöter ju nästan aldrig det.
Men det där är väl liksom den starka entreprenören kan jag tänka, men jag måste ändå förhålla mig till en ägare, en styrelse eller också, då tror jag det håller lite band på en säkert sätt, men du kan verkligen bara gå loss.
Det är väl också en fördel med att ha, man upplever en stark ledningsgrupp.
Många av dem som är, eller alla är säkert smartare och bättre än mig.
På sina specifika områden så menar jag också på IQ-mässigt smartare än mig.
Och då blir det att du liksom, du får, du måste värdera dina åsikter, du måste anpassa dig, vilket gör att du kanske blir en lite bättre människa.
Tycker du att det är skönt att ha den kontrollinstansen på sista nivå där?
Eller tycker du att det är lite störigt att behöva rapportera till folk?
Jag gillar ju självständighet.
Jag är ju en entreprenör, även om det är svårt att tro det på mitt CV och så där.
Men jag har ju ändå drivit något bolag vid sidan om och sådant.
Men jag är, vad heter det, jag älskar ju självständighet.
Och det är liksom, det sättet man får självständighet och det är ju någonstans att bygga förtroende.
Så att säkerställa att man håller vad man lovar och levererar på det man sagt skapar ju förutsättningarna för frihet.
Så det blir vi också då.
Och det är alla sammanhangar där man inte får vara fri, bryrig och lämna ämnet.
Är det därför det blir, när vi började det här samtalet så var du lite inne på, dina kollegor, de ska få göra, eller de ska få vara den de är typ.
Är det för att det är din sån starka drivkraft, så då har du genomgått, så de ska också få den.
De ska få den.
Ja, jag tror det.
Att det ligger något i, också för att uppleva att det är efterträmmansvärt.
Och att, och jag tror det är universellt, att få, det behöver inte nödvändigtvis vara att man ska få frihet att göra vad man vill, men alltså, välja att t.ex.
om man gillar att jobba med det strukturerade och miljöet, som inte är fri, i alla fall få möjlighet att göra valet.
Jag tror det är, det är väl liksom, mänskligt med också någon sorts utveckling, att ett samhälle borde verka för det liksom.
Ja, det var ringligt.
För att avsluta på en inte fullt så seriös not, så tänkte jag att, som sista fråga, om vi bara ska, jag tänker att gymgrossisten behöver ju samköra med hela influencervärlden och hela den skaran av människor som syns i träningen.
Om du fick välja allt annat lika, ingenting förändras, men du bara fick plocka bort varenda influencer som finns i hela Sverige.
Hade du gjort det då?
Tänk att bara slippa hela den huvudvärken.
Nej men det är så här, det jag tycker man borde kunna slippa.
Jag tar det som ett ja.
Du börjar så här, och sukunderar mig som en politiker, svarsgubbe här.
Men jag tror ju att influencers är ju bara människor va.
Så att, och det har ju blivit någonstans ett yrke, så det är klart att de ska få sina skar och verka.
Det jag går och känner på dagligen nu, det är ju så här, vad ska ens barn jobba med?
Och det kanske är influencers som är det enda rimliga alternativet, det och typ fotbollsspel eller någonting.
Alla, och det kommer vi att ta i vårt jobb.
Så att ta bort även influencer, kändes som att nej det, jag säger nej då, jag säger nej.
Okej, ja, jag köper det.
Johan, ett stort enormt tack för att du var med.
Jag tror detta är mitt favoritavsnitt någonsin, så det känns ganska passande att detta avslutar säsongen inför sommaren.
Det där säger du säkert efter varje eller?
Det brukar jag göra, men jag brukar klippa bort det.
Men här ska jag låta dig vara på.
Allraj, tack så mycket.
Ja, det märks att du varit chef länge.
Fan.
Ni pratar så snällt på Gymmro-system.